trump needs to win in 2024.
we had cash patel on the show
and
my attitude is just fire everybody
as soon as trump wins again just get in
there and just fire everyone
you're fired the the line he's famous
for he's just well and the press
strategy should be different too so i
was there uh working for john solomon
who's hopefully going to come on with
you guys soon uh with just the news and
that was the year in 2020 when we were
launching so it was the last year the
trump presidency and it was so hard to
get in the room credentialing so i was
covering the white house for him and
because the pandemic the
white house correspondents association
was very dictatorial about first of all
they're that way normally about who's
allowed in the room but because of covet
they
severely constrained who was in the room
so as a startup working for a guy who
was you know reporting the truth john
solomon during pandemic it was really
hard to get in the room and i only got
in the room because of kaylee mcanini
allowed me in the room myself and one
american news and
from uh one american news chanel rion
their founder
she she opened my eyes to what's
happening in that press briefing room
and our understanding is that if trump's
comes back he's going to change the
strategy of what happens in that press
briefing room because right now the wha
is a private non-profit that's a white
house correspondence exactly yeah so
alex jones press secretary
well yeah but as far as allowing yes she
said yes
no no it was more it was more the other
way around as far as like who's who's in
the room to ask the president a question
because right now the whca is a liberal
good old boys club that's been around
for a hundred years that is dictating to
the to the president who's allowed on
government property and they don't allow
conservatives in the room and if you're
a conservative and you try to get a seat
on the board for wha you can't so chanel
rion from one american news started her
own uh competing nonprofit and uh the
trump white house we you know was
considering recognizing that and getting
more equal representation in the room
because if you see the questions that
they were asking trump they were not
fair questions right like my first
question that i asked trump when i was
in in the white house press briefing
room was i asked him a question about
what was happening with hong kong and it
was uh you know jimmy lai had just been
arrested so i'm asking about china and
hong kong chanel asked a question about
iran policy in the middle east
and then i think it was somebody from
nbc asked a question about q anon so
it's like the supposed you know
conspiracy right-wing journalists are
asking stepson of policy questions and
then you have these other you know white
house correspondents association
establishment types they're there to
make trump look bad and he was he was he
was
uh you know egged on because he thought
that it would win him points and one
points with the base but i think it
turned off the suburban women the more
middle you know middle of the road
people and so from what i understand
that would be one thing that he would
change uh substantially i think it's
good i i made a couple posts on
instagram for this called the cnn
challenge and it was
that i mean there's no real challenge it
was turn on fox news
and then
whatever the news is
switch to cnn and they'll be talking
about trump
so
i used to i used to have cnn playing in
the background all the time
because you know my my mentality was
when news breaks
they'll report it really really quickly
and then one day i was just sitting in
you know i was like recording something
and then i turned the volume back up and
then i'm thinking i'm watching and i'm
just like have they been talking about
trump all day
like there was a there was like a storm
or something happened i'm like so i
changed the channel and it was like
riots in iran
and then i was like wow
all right so i'm on fox news now i
normally don't watch fox news and then
uh something else was happening i think
it was a a hurricane was coming
and i turned on cnn and they're like
doing a round table about donald trump
and then i was just like this is crazy i
switched to fox news and they're like
here's what you do expect the upcoming
storm and i was like i guess i'll leave
fox on
listen it's in cbs
when fox news started
les moonves who was head of cbs at the
time corporate came into the washington
dc newsroom and convened us all around
the conference table and said
is what's happening with fox this early
popularity is it real or is it something
that just crazy people are watching
and i was too young you know i
too young to speak up and finally
understood that that's the wrong thing
to do sometimes because i used to speak
up too much in bad situ in situations
where i shouldn't i kept my mouth shut
because i was fairly new around the
table every other journalist there said
it's just a fake stupid thing that craig
that speaking to crazies meantime i had
discovered what you had as a former cnn
person i used to have cnn on in my you
know office all day just to see if there
was breaking news and there used to be
and when fox came on fox had news before
the other networks did and before cnn
did often sometimes a couple of days
before and then the others would follow
it up so i started
being sort of the contrarian that i am
putting fox news on in my office and of
course that gets me pegged i'm sure
around the newsroom instead of
gee she's smart because we're all
watching one thing but we're all
supposed to be kind of gathering
you know breaking news and at least one
person's watching another network and
learning new things
um i'm sure i was pegged as sort of that
crazy fox watcher but i saw the same
thing you did tim yeah
and then i just stopped watching
well a lot of people stopped watching
cnn well now they're saying with the new
ownership they're going to purge all of
that stuff out of cnn
that that's that's just the death knell
well
also you can't it's too this is my my
opinion my thought and i interviewed a
lot of current and former cnn's for the
last book that i wrote about all of this
it's too endemic you can try it's sort
of like trump trying to get rid of the
establishment you know bureaucracy
that's the deep state you might say
you can try all you want but they're
really entrenched and strong and the
news industry whether it's not that
everybody feels the same way but so many
people in the news industry and the way
they're being brought up in journalism
colleges
um i i don't i think that's a tough road
to hoe at cnn
i think
did i say i think
rhode island
i think freedom i'm triggered
meritocracy
and honesty are winning
i think you look at uh
the the the collapse of the
establishment press
you look at the expansion of gun rights
the narrative isn't working their lies
are not working
a regular person will hear we need
background checks and a ban on assault
weapons
but now they can google it and the ones
who do go hey wait a minute we already
have background checks
oh but it's a gun show loophole really
what's that google oh there isn't one
that's a lie it's a political term not a
real thing oh that's weird well what
about assault weapons
assaults have a definition wikipedia
says assault weapon is ill-defined it
typically refers to a pistol grip or
forward accessories or maybe magazine
size but there's no real definition so
when regular people are they hear these
things from joe biden
joe biden i got to tell you is red pill
and people like crazy when he's like
nine millimeter is gonna blow along out
of the body
you're gonna get some regular persons
you'll be like whoa really i was
watching a movie they that what and
they're gonna google and go what
that's not real
what else isn't real
if joe biden was wrong about that what
else was he wrong about i think you're
right
when you overplay your hands i think the
organized campaign of propagandists to
try to create this artificial reality to
make fringe things seem as though they
are the norm to make the majority of
people think that they are in the
minority you know this is what social
media and the internet's been all about
people get wise and the truth takes a
little longer to be told but the truth
usually survives it just takes more time
yeah but well
part of it is yes the language like
that's why we made the worktionary is
because the language it's it's news
concepts it's new things that people
aren't as familiar and then once they
understand it they're like they reject
it the body rejects that organ
transplant that so and a new one right
now is the esg you know if if you say if
you ask a random person on the street
what do you think about esg you know
equity social governance for investing
you know they're not going to know what
that means but then if you explain what
it means which is
uh let's uh use capitalism and something
that should be apolitical to bludgeon
and uh push in a socialist leftist
agenda they're gonna say that's not okay
it should be apolitical but but they
don't know the the lingo yet but they're
waking up and that's why you have people
you know creating strive capital uh you
know the guy who wrote woke inc is is
starting um
what you got to do is when you go to
people
talk about how esg is good
esg is it's so you want to invest and
i'm not mean this literally no financial
advice you say you really got to take a
look at this esg stuff the idea is
simple
instead of merit you know skill
determining whether or not a business
succeeds we are going to focus on
political activism
so like
if if a company is going to sell solar
panels instead of hiring engineers who
have graduated with degrees we're going
to hire activists
that's going to make you a good buck
and then people are going to be like
what
how is my solar panel company going to
make money if they're doing political
activities and not selling solar panels
it reminds me of iron man when in the in
the first one he says oh marvel
reference
he uh tony stark announces they're not
doing weapons anymore and then they have
that scene of jim cramer saying the
stock and then he hits the baseball the
mug with the baseball bat and says this
is a weapons company that doesn't sell
weapons
that's what esg is right you're
investing
i just got to say i'm not going to tell
anybody what to invest in
my understanding is that the esg
companies did really really poorly like
in terms of you know um return that's a
shock yeah i i don't know i'm just if if
you want to invest in
you know a meat processing plant that
cares more about political activism than
processing meat
all right yes you gotta i i think that's
one of the stupidest possible
investments a single human being can
make you might as well just literally
donate the money to a charity at least
then you can write it off wait hold on
you don't think that i should invest in
the vegan run meat processing plant no
that actually i think it's a good idea
no if there is a
vegan
vegan run meat processing well i i i
should walk that back what i what i mean
say is
vegan meat plant i thought you were
saying i thought you said that's enough
that grows meat
no but i mean like i thought that's what
you're saying yeah i thought you were
saying a plant that makes fake meat i'm
like that's a good idea actually
look i mean if that were possible yes
absolutely invest in that i'm sorry i
didn't mean to give you guys bad
financial advice it wasn't financial
advice as we like to say on the show
well there's a real-time example of that
just happened uh once you explain it to
the average you know to shareholders so
carl icahn is this hedge fund
billionaire and he he's obsessed with
the treatment of pregnant pigs and he
was trying to force mcdonald's to change
their practices to meet his standards
not the industry but breast pac best
practice standards he said it wasn't
good enough and so he tried to force his
people to be on the board of mcdonald's
but thank god mcdonald's just uh
rejected it the shareholders and the
they vote and they said no keep keep
your activists off our board they have
no clue what they're talking about with
actual meat processing not to mention
you know
low
low income people a lot of people
average people shop at mcdonald's this
is going to make food more expensive for
them so you have a hedge fund
billionaire trying to make food way more
expensive for average people
and they rejected it i just want to pull
up this forbes advisor article it's not
easy being green why esg is
underperforming why is esg
underperforming 2022 i just want to say
if you think investing money
into
anti-meritocratic systems you are a
[ __ ] also because if these
companies were profitable you wouldn't
have to invent something called esg
companies would already be doing the
thing that would make them money and
make them more profitable as a business
you wouldn't have to threaten them with
a bad esg score or incentivize them with
a good one here's the pitch sheamus
we're taking on investors for my company
okay what do we do
we make pizzas yes beautiful now chicago
style who's leading the team
black lives matter of course
what now do they have experience making
pizza no no but their hearts are in
equity right equity i don't look i don't
want my pizza made by someone whose
heart isn't in the right place i hope
you have some women up there at the top
exactly i hope they have well what do
you mean by woman not hope mandate yeah
yeah someone who identifies as a woman
is good enough for me yeah
yeah
yeah had three six foot five dudes but
they've recently transitioned yeah i've
been wondering why this is kind of
related the trend we've probably all
noticed in the past 10 years which are
ads on tv for products and companies
that aren't telling you about their
product they're telling you what they
donate and what they do
and i started asking young people
because it doesn't appeal to me i don't
i don't buy my products based on that
apparently young people do i was saying
do you care do you care that this
company is spending money advertising to
you or would you rather have advertising
to you about the good that they do in
some social realm or some position they
take or would you rather just have them
sell you the best product at the lowest
price this is a good idea we should do a
commercial for tim cast and have it not
in any way tell anything about that
we were kind of talking about that last
night let's do it yeah for sure we
should let's do what let's do an overly
woke commercial for tim cass and put on
tucker one million i keep saying that
the problem is like we need managerial
power to get these things done like we
want to do the chicken city one
and we're gonna do our pillow and it's
never happened so i don't like talking
about things unless we're like in the
pipeline to do it but projects fall
apart but uh let's do it did you see the
saturday night live skit about that
about the woke commercials and they were
giving the awards for i was shocked
saturday night live did this it's very
funny the most woke commercials yes
you've got to look that up it's very
funny about that's the real shock they
do yes
find it
i will yeah i can't believe snl did
something funny like that's insane it's
funny thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you